joseph mocarzel bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france on voit
bien les libanais qui sont décidés à
aller jusqu'au bout a demandé à réclamer
le départ de ce gouvernement qu'ils
accusent d'être en partie responsables
de la double explosion qui a soufflé une
partie de beyrouth mardi dernier ce que
l'on peut craindre de nouveaux
rassemblements aujourd'hui dans la
capitale
je crois que les rassemblements qui ont
déjà commencé leur ont passé l'été les
gens sont déterminés ils ne s'arrêteront
que si les mots il ya quelque chose qui
se passe au niveau de la classe
politique que le gouvernement
démissionne qu'il y ait vraiment un
changement ou un début de changement
radical je crois que j'avais invité à
certains moments pensants ou donnons la
chance gouvernement actuel de faire
quelque chose ce gouvernement a approuvé
qu'il était incapable d'exercer la
ministre de l'information elle-même dans
cette émission qui l'a dit je crois que
ça va continuer jusqu'à les mots qu'il y
ait un point de rupture à l'échelle
politique
alors justement on a pu voir deux
écouter entendre en tout cas de nombreux
slogans ils avaient beaucoup de jeunes
libanais dans la rue qui affirme l'état
c'est nous ils veulent que ce soit eux
aujourd'hui qui représente justement
leur pays par classe dirigeante actuelle
quelles sont les marges de manoeuvre du
président libanais peut-il justement
essayer de demander à lui-même le départ
de cette classe politique débouté le
département le président après l'accord
on appelle ça la deuxième république
le président n'a plus beaucoup de
pouvoirs à ce niveau il ne peut pas
demander l'admission
[Musique]
enfin il peut pas changer le parlement
il peut juste de donner un avis c'est un
peu le papa de la république
mais le ce qui est la décision est entre
les mains et de la chambre du président
de la chambre et de la chambre elle-même
soit du gouvernement qui peut
démissionner si cette liste jeudi bout
de ce gouvernement d'affirmer le temps
tunis a démissionné démissionne devons
changer le gouvernement
- que ça il change dont les ministres
comme ça c'est fait avec miss affaires
étrangères et les deux ministres qui
viennent de quitter actuellement on est
on est en attente ces deux jours
peut-être un changement à ce niveau soit
le premier ministre démissionne et c'est
possible soit il ya un vote de confiance
il va se faire au parlement qui décidera
du sort du gouvernement actuel mais les
gens demanderont plus les gens demandent
des élections législatives anticipées
ils veulent vraiment que il considère
que ceux qui sont là ne les représente
plus ils ont été élus démocratiquement
mais aujourd'hui la rue ne veut plus et
c'est là le principal enjeu de ces
manifestations voulons qu'il arrivait à
changer la chambre je n'en suis pas sûr
ou le moment justement face à dire le
premier ministre libanais a déclaré
qu'il allait aujourd'hui présentée en
conseil de ministres proposition de
d'élections législatives anticipées va
tirer aller jusqu'au bout
à votre avis vous avez le premier
ministre actuel n'est pas logé par
partie 2
les groupes dirigeants dans ce sens des
grandes des grandes commandes des grands
partis qui déniche donc il est censé
être le trait entre enfin égale distance
en tout le monde en fait il ne l'est pas
réellement mais il le prétend lui ne
peut pas décider de ça lui me proposer
au gouvernement des élections
législatives anticipées
et là le débat c'est ce qu'on craint
c'est ce que le peuple crève que le
débat tourne dans la chambre qu'ils
acceptent la chose mais qu'il dise voilà
il faut une nouvelle loi électorale
nouvelle loi électorale au liban va
prendre des mois et des années pour être
élu comme à chaque fois l'expérience est
là il y aura des mois de discussions de
débats etc
pour cette fois on n'a pas beaucoup
d'espoir que les élections anticipées se
tiendront sauf si vraiment il a sorti la
rue oblige les députés à lui ou qu'il y
ait beaucoup de démission parmi les
députés
à ce moment là aujourd'hui on attend que
le groupe de résidants de l'ancien
ministre hariri démission par exemple le
groupe des forces libanaises démissionne
c'est à dire des poids dans le tas
d'enfants en nombre je parle de députés
au parlement qui arriveront à faire
tomber ce parlement dernière question
aujourd'hui beyrouth le liban en général
doit se reconstruire on sait qu hier une
conférence des donateurs s'est tenue
sous l'égide de la france et de l'onu
252 millions d'euros des dons était
promis au cours de cette réunion
comment s'assurer que cette somme arrive
bien aux libanais qui accusent la classe
politique de corruption
égouttez le premier le président mac
l'on a fait pour le liban ce que les
politiciens libanais non parce que je
vous parle de ce que j'entends dans la
rue de ce qui se dit il a redonné espoir
aux dix bals et qu' il ya quelqu'un la
classe internationale et avec le mcs
l'on n'est pas seul il l'a dit il est
venu avec en prendre non vraiment un
l'aval du monde y compris les américains
qui font pression sur le liban donc
l'espoir renaissant sait maintenant
qu'il a donné au liban et ça c'est très
important pour la reconstruction
l'argent bien sûr il n'est pas suffisant
ce qui a été donnée maintenant cette
poule est pas suffisant mais il va pas
les contenus chance donc les gens se
jouent bricier à pouvoir vraiment sauver
des vies pouvoir bâtir des hôpitaux
préparer des écoles loger des gens qui
sont sans abri on a plus de 300000
personnes sans abri et je pense que
c'est un début le si le gouvernement
actuel de dépenses correctement
principales luttes le dépenser c'est
clair que c'est l'onu qui va prendre en
charge la dépense de cet argent dans en
toute transparence et directement vers
les concernés et là c'est facile de
libre n'est pas un grand pays
facile de vraiment cerner le problème
directement les besoins et de donner
directement à ceux qui en ont besoin
les fonds que ce soit hôpitaux etc puis
si je vais à mon avis et c'est là où la
france peut vraiment aider c'est au
niveau des bâtisses des anciennes
bâtisses traditionnelle et là je pense
qu'on va faire appel avait organisme
vraiment de patrimoine qui viendront
voir vraiment voir qu'est ce qu'il faut
pour ne pas donner dans les années qui
suivent les maisons qui s'effondre et
qui tuent des gens là cet est capital
c'est vital on en est conscient
la france en est conscient le monde en
est conscient mais là c'est beaucoup
beaucoup d'efforts et je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup plus que 250 millions à verser
sans compter pour la reconstruction du
port va coûter beaucoup plus cher
merci beaucoup en tout cas joseph ou
quinzaine avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes député
suppléant des français de l'étranger